faut pas oublier conseillé d'en tirer
aussi dans les revendications du gilet
jaune
donc on voudrait nous tellement que
c'est des manifestations se passe plus
clairement possible pour qu'ils puissent
revendiquer
il ya des choses qui sont en cours mais
voilà ils sont débordés par tous qui
cassent leur actuellement
[Musique]
à la fois de la manip rentrez chez vous
vous ne restez pas statiques les
regardez pas ce qui se passe mais les
gilets jaunes ils ont évolué sur le fait
de mettre en place un dispositif de
sécurité ce positif de sécurité c'est
bien de mettre un un cordon de sécurité
pour moi il n'est pas adapté sur les fin
de manif on l'a vu samedi ou après que
tous les cadres dg les jeunes se soient
écartés de la manifestation
y'a plus rien il ya plus de dispositifs
de sécurité et là on en arrive aux
troubles à l'ordre public
[Musique]
la relation avec les jets les jaunes a
rien à dire franchement sur toutes les
manifestations
c'est ce qui vient en plus c'est les
casseurs c'est tout ce qu'ils viennent
les extrêmes qui viennent de faire en
sorte que le moment j'ai des jeunes
dégénère à la fin on ne voit plus que
l'image des débordements les 45 minutes
tout ce qui s'est passé donc aussi les
revendications les entend plus l'image
l'image de gilet jaune à les casseurs
cas c'est bien ça c'est pas du tout
l'image que je pense qu'il va le
revendiquer on a vu un sur les
manifestations loi de travail qu'on a pu
connaître où ça a été des manifestations
qui étaient très gérer avec beaucoup de
failles ou en laisse et éventuellement
des casseurs venir alors c'était soit la
manifestation a dégénéré des départs ou
alors en milieu de parcours ou à la fin
donc là on est plutôt sur ça on est sur
une manifestation qui part normalement
et c'est en fin de manifestation après
je parle paris sur d autres endroits ça
peut dégénérer à n'importe quel moment
il ya une réelle évolution sur la
manifestation des légendes pourquoi
parce que on avait un dispositif qui
était statique on essaie les gens sur
les champs-elysées ont fait en sorte ça
a été le pugilat
une des jeunes pour moi la plus grosse
erreur ça ne vient pas des gilet jaune
ça vient de la préfecture de police qui
a laissé un chantier accessible à tout
le monde
nous on a vu les images sont ceni mais
ça va être une folie d'entrée se faire
insulter pour nous c'est d'une banalité
on a on apprend ça fait pas plaisir
j'avais pris plaisir et mythes mois
qu'on m'insulte personnellement c'est
pas grave qu'on a su de ma famille ça me
dérange mais c'est surtout de subir la
direction les déchets de projets qu'il
compte on peut voir moi ce qui me fait
peur c'est que lorsque la compagnie elle
est engagée c'est qu'on revienne pas
qu'on paie est réellement c'est la
crainte de tout le monde prenne à la
fatigue qui s'installe un on a des
compagnies d'hier soir j'étais avec des
compagnies 12 wickens avec 12 12 ou ken
consécutifs ont ce week-end que les
collectes romagne on a des compagnies
sur le 1er décembre et le 8 décembre qui
ont fait vingt heures de travail sans
manger
la fatigue elle est là alors répertoriés
au niveau police nationale on est à plus
de 1200 collègues qui sont blessés
déclaré blaise est contusionnée on a
énormément de petits bobos
j'ai un collègue qui a eu la main cassée
qui est resté sur le terrain et la
semaine d'après il était encore présent
il s'est reblessé leur y est obligé de
s'arrêter
des collègues qui sont connotés prix
tioté roué de coups on a le collègue de
la crs 40 2 qui a été pris aussi à
partie à morlaix qui ont subi un
préjudice physique et moral de collègues
de la série suit pareil on a un collègue
de la crs 36 exactement de metz paris
qui a été qui a été touché peut-être
tout des collègues qui sont blessés la
seule chose c'est que on n'entend parler
que des blessés côté des jets les jeunes
et des casseurs mois la limite les
blessés gilet jaune je peux les
comprendre les coudes les côtés
classement n'ont rien à faire là rien à
faire s'ils viennent s'ils gagnent au
contact m'a tant pis pour eux